you know welcome to this video I'm
opponent is km - from Serbia maybe slow
week yeah I'm sorry really sorry but
I've tried to improve ok um the f3 line
what am i but whatever i recommending in
my own book I think I'm going to have c5
at the book and then then B 5 very very
sharp line but very interesting leading
to to gambit plain white some most
consistent move now is e5 e 598 f4 and
this is this is rare at least ok first
age 6 or not I must admit that of course
I have forgotten what maybe h6 first and
he can never take anyway because it it
kills the darkest class but I wonder
about this now e5 is the critical news
but he didn't play that you know
non-threatening Knight takes e4 and this
is tricky now 94 Bishop the 893 check
this is why Knight takes e4 as a threat
now black is very quick now on the evil
he's simply ignoring it
Queen f5s
yeah but okay I have played for this
idea so I should execute it Jack deth
should just win the game at the end
black will have an extra piece or an
extra piece I'm just going to take the
queen and he won't rescue the bishop on
d8 and take my night and only fulfill
one duty at the time can take him yeah
rupee one rupee a time another piece up
I also threatened Knight e3 check so I
don't really see a move for white
I think that Bishop g5 is a really
questionable at least you need to react
to the rookie 8 idea okay okay
Chang withdrawing with chicken and then
take my five reasons yeah I could take
d5 with the temple on the bishop it's
just uh just an extra piece and in this
position with rupee eight it's already a
slightly slightly tricky for white he
needs to to block the e-file so somehow
maybe yeah maybe a move like that
something like that is probably probably
right and then I'll just continue to to
develop with them let's eighty six and
then maybe maybe c4 Bishop c5 or a six
it's an interesting position also Knight
d7 all the way to g6 this is how I
usually react in this repertoire against
f3 we'll do the quick c5 this is similar
to the Ben Oni but differences that you
get him b5 in quickly and you have
really quick development and whites
development is a bit clumsy and yeah
moves like that you simply cannot afford
here black some in stably winning okay
thanks for watching